LIST.
THANKS FOR THE SUPPORT.
>> Sean: HAVE A GREAT SHOW, MY
FRIEND.
>> Pete: THANK YOU, BROTHER.
I APPRECIATE IT.
I AM PETE HEGSETH AND FOR LAUREN
GRAHAM AND THIS IS A
SPECIAL EDITION OF "THE
INGRAHAM ANGLE."
HAVE WE SEEN THIS STORY BEFORE?
RUSSIA COLLUSION, UKRAINIAN
PHONE CALL, ALLEGED HUSH MONEY
PAYMENTS TO STORMY DANIELS.
NEVER-TRUMPERS ALWAYS THINK THEY
HAVE THE FORMER PRESIDENT RIGHT
WHERE THEY WANT HIM.
THE AFTERMATH OF THE MAR-A-LAGO
RAID, IT HAS BEEN NO DIFFERENT.
>> LET'S ABOUT TRUMPERS REACTION
WHICH HAS BEEN WHICH IS TO
THROW ANY CRITICISM BACK IN THE
FACE OF THE DOJ.
DO YOU GET THE SENSE HE FEELS
LIKE THE WALLS ARE CLOSING IN?
>> I THINK HE IS VERY WORRIED.
I DON'T THINK HE'LL ADMIT IT.
I THINK FOR THE FIRST TIME
THINGS ARE REALLY -- I'M GOING
TO SAY THE WALLS ARE CLOSING IN.
>> Pete: YES, THE OFT
REPEATED, NEVER REALIZED WALLS
THAT ARE CLOSING IN.
LIKE THE KNIVES ARE OUT.
IT ISN'T JUST THE RESISTANCE
FOLKS PLAYING INTO THIS.
BUT ALSO BIDEN'S DOJ.
IN LAST NIGHT'S CLOSE TO
MIDNIGHT FILING IN RESPONSE TO
HIS REQUEST FOR AN INDEPENDENT
SPECIAL MASTER TO DETERMINE WHAT
WOULD ACTUALLY BE APPLICABLE,
THEY WENT OUT OF THEIR WAY TO
PROVIDE EVEN MORE FODDER FOR THE
CHATTERING CLASS AND THE DAMNING
LANGUAGE IN LEAPS OF LOGIC ONLY
INTENSIFY.
>> HE'S GOT TO WORRY THAT HIS
OWN ATTORNEYS ARE GOING TO TURN
ON HIM.
HIS OWN ATTORNEY, ONE OF HIS
ATTORNEY SIGNED THIS DOCUMENT
THAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO BEFORE
SAYING SHE HAS TURNED OVER
EVERYTHING THE TRUCK HAS
AUTHORIZED HER TO SAY THAT.
THE OTHER ATTORNEY EVIDENTLY
DRAFTED THAT DOCUMENT.
BOTH ARE IMPLICATED IN THIS AND
BOTH RIGHT NOW ARE LOOKING VERY
MUCH ACTIVELY AND JAIL TIME.
>> Pete: EVERYONE IS GOING TO
TURN ON HIM.
IT'S HAPPENING AT THIS MOMENT.
OF COURSE I CAN ONLY LEAD TO ONE
CONCLUSION, SOMETHING THAT THEY
HAVE BEEN PINING FOR OVER THE
PAST SEVEN YEARS.
>> WHAT WE HAVE SEEN NO, HAVING
CROSSED THE RUBICON AND SENT
THOSE FBI AGENTS DOWN THERE TO
DO THAT SEARCH AND SEIZURE.
THE DOJ, LAYING IT ON THE FLOOR
AND PUTTING THESE PHOTOGRAPHS
OUT.
THEY ARE NOT JUST SLAMMING,
SPIKING THE BALL.
THEY ARE IMPLICITLY OR
EXPLICITLY, TIPPING THEIR HAND
TOO.
I UNDERSTAND A WORLD IN WHICH NO
MERRICK GARLAND COULD NOT IN THE
AMERICAN TIGHTROPE.
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE HEADED.
>> Pete: WHAT IS THE REALITY?
WE DON'T PUT ANYTHING PAST THE
GARLAND JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
WE CAUGHT THIS NOTE IN THE
EIGHTH PARAGRAPH OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" SWEEPING
ARTICLE ABOUT LAST NIGHT'S
FILING.
IN INCLUDING THIS TELLING LINE.
EIGHTH PARAGRAPH.
DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS ARE NOT
EXPECTED TO FILE CHARG